[Music]
bobby's with us in columbia south
carolina hey bobby welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave uh and it's george right uh
this is ken today but i'll answer it
with me george was
george is nicer than ken yeah yeah
i can't i can't argue that he's the
nicest person on the planet he is yeah
he's nicer than all of us that's good
stuff good personality qualities right
there right yeah okay sorry about all
that how can we help
i'm basically you know recommended to
you from a previous boss and a longtime
friend of mine uh you know very humble
man uh man of god brandon blake thank
you very much i hope you hear this um
i'm kind of in a pickle right now dave
i'm 24 years old i'm a young father i
got a three-year-old i'll be three in
december absolute pride and joy in my
life and my biggest form of motivation
um and my wife and me we're still
together
um i'm currently living with some
relatives
and i've been here for about seven
months uh my wife was working full-time
and just switched to staying at home to
watching her son while i work full-time
i just got a really nice job the best
one i've had since i've been working in
the professional field 401k offered paid
time off
bonus structure things of that nature
i'm in a very weird position though with
how to take you know i'm very young with
my professional career i want to set up
my foundation with investing properly
as we stand right now my debt i only
have about twenty thousand dollars of
debt seventeen thousand dollars in
student loans about two thousand dollars
in medical bills and how much do you
make
um thirty five thousand dollars a year
um if my bonus comes out the way that it
should this next year it'll be at 40.
working 40 hours
40 hours a week yes sir
your baby's how old
uh he'll be three in december december
6.
what was your wife doing before she quit
she was working as a cake decorator for
lowe's foods um and has since lost her
position mainly due to it was during
covid so it got pretty hectic
and right now she's just staying at home
and interestingly enough she also has an
international business degree four-year
university from rollins
but she doesn't have any direct
experience working in the field not even
a job like a starting job that would
even be relatable to that yeah
what's the pickle that you're in you've
given us a lot of details what's the
pickle
my pickle is i have two options right
now um you know eventually inevitably i
want to move out my mom and dad are
generous enough to let me a little allow
me to live rent free um so the only
thing i'm having is living expenses and
a couple other payments
um but i need to figure out you know if
i mean obviously saving money is what
needs to happen um but where to put that
money is the question no there's not a
question
you're broke and you're living with your
parents you need to pile up some money
in a savings account and get out of
there
yeah you don't need to start don't worry
about investing and don't start your
401k you're broken in debt
and you guys have got to do something in
this household to increase your incomes
so since you're only working 40 hours
you need an extra job and your wife
needs to start doing some freaking cake
decorating while she's at home with a
three-year-old
yeah no you're right you're not wrong
dave um and i guess my next question is
you know to make my the smartest
decision possible um you know my credit
score was pretty good at 700.
um my thought process was
getting either a mortgage on a house no
you're broke
you need to go get a one bedroom or
two-bedroom apartment as cheap as you
can get and you need to pile up cash as
much as you can and you need to be
working 80 hours a week and she needs to
start working 30 hours a week when the
kid's down
so she can get some other income coming
in you guys need to get your income up
50 to 70 000 immediately and start
paying these debts off and get out from
under your parent's roof yesterday
yes sir my question is in regards to the
rent with renting i mean as you know
rental properties the money you put in
goes into a hole you don't get it back
honey you're broke
you're a renter
you don't buy a house when you're broke
you are broke and in debt you make 35
000 a year and have a three year old
you're 24 years old you don't go buy a
house right now this house will be a
curse to you you're trying to mix
long-term
issues in with your short-term
emotions and you need to get the
short-term stuff taken care of you need
a big pile of money for an emergency and
to move and to get out and you guys need
to get your incomes up and then you
begin to attack the debt and when the
debt is gone you build an emergency fund
a fully funded big emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses then
we'll start talking about saving for a
house you're not buying a house for
three two to three years from today if
you're wise
it's just hard dave because you know
with rent it's not hard
it's not hard you're 24
you'll be 27 when you own your first
house it's not hard at all yeah somebody
has told you that renting is throwing
money away and you can't get past that
thought and it's simply not throwing
money away for two years when stacy and
i moved here to join dave this was the
move for me we took two years and rented
because we wanted to make sure we were
going to the right place we wanted to
make sure that we were going to lock in
and and dive in and we had to save money
to be able to get the kind of house that
we felt that we wanted to get we weren't
throwing money away that's a false
narrative and you're not hearing
the wisdom and the truth here that dave
just gave you the baby steps work every
time but only if you get this mindset
out of your head that renting is wasting
money renting is buying patients while
you're too broke to buy oh that's good
you're buying you're buying time
and honey you're so broke you live with
your parents
that's how broke you are you don't need
to go from that to owning a home
you you need to get out get the debts
paid off build up an emergency fund
build a foundation for your young family
slow your butt down
you're okay you got plenty of time